Let's go next to our caller.
Let's try the seven Oh eight area code.
Who's calling today from seven Oh eight.
Oh let's see.
Seven oh eight was dropped on the truck.
Oh, you're on.
Okay.
Yeah, go ahead.
Seven.
Oh wait.
Hi.
I'm Daniel from the Chicago land area.
Hey Daniel.
Um, so I've noticed, you know, I'm, I'm like
a young guy and I'm like very into politics
and I've been following your show and a couple
other films for the past year or so.
And I've noticed that like I'm very into policy,
but like when I talked to my friends, you
know, there's a big gap in being informed
I think and like also misinformation.
Sure.
And I'm starting to think like that, you know,
as much as we try to find solutions and try
to convince others of like progressive solutions
and things like that.
Like when I look at say a second choice poll,
like Biden, like most of Biden's second choice
of theirs, his supporters, second choices,
Bernie Sanders.
And that like just doesn't make sense to me.
Um, which means that like there must be some,
you know like the large of the public is not
really informed on a lot of these issues.
Absolutely.
I mean listen my, my interpretation of that
would be that this is heavily driven that
that reality that that for Biden supporters
they're number one alternative is Bernie is
basically a popularity and name recognition
thing combined with personality.
It's a Biden's really well known.
He was the former vice president.
Lots of people who liked the Obama administration
or at least liked it in relation to the Trump
administration maybe leaning towards Biden
early as a result of that.
Beyond that Bernie is sort of like the most
well known and he's relatively, he has high
favor ability of the other candidates.
Elizabeth Warren is also relatively well known,
so it makes perfect sense and you're completely
right.
How could somebody who is supporting Biden
on policy say, my next choice is Bernie, but,
but I think that when you understand how politics
works in the United States, it actually does
make sense.
Do you think that like there is a chance to
kind of, I know this is largely what like
a lot of the progressive movement is about,
is about doing politics based on policy and
not necessarily name recognition or identity.
Um, do you think there's a chance in the selection
that this can be, I know that's like Bernie's
main message.
Like you go back to when he was debating Hillary
and he's like, I don't want to talk about
your emails.
I want to talk about the policy.
Yeah.
Do you think there's a chance in the selection
that that could actually, you know, that could
be the favored, uh, way to evaluate the candidates?
Well, listen, Elizabeth Warren has been making
gains for about the last four months, about
a point to a point and a half a month on policy.
I mean she, she, her town halls are very policy
centric.
She's putting out a ton of policy papers on
our website and that has worked in a sort
of slow and steady way for her.
The problem is that when you look at the first
democratic debates, the format doesn't allow
for deep policy discussion.
10 candidates on a stage on a minute to respond
in 32nd rebuttals.
That doesn't policy is impossible.
They're okay.
It's talking points and zingers when you're
running against Trump who doesn't even understand
policy, but is very effective in a sort of
influence, charisma, a way to people who are
at least somewhat predisposed to like his
style.
It's also hard to really dig deep on policy
because whoever goes up against him, if they
try to focus on policy, Trump's not going
to have it.
He can't debate policy.
So I actually don't really see a path for
policy to ultimately be the focus in this
election.
Unfortunately, there's going to have to be
some other way to defeat Trump.
[inaudible] so you think of that like progressive's
have to play into that.
You think like Bernie might have to play into
like, you know, he started his campaign with
um, a big speech about like where he came
from, like his identity.
Do you think he has to favor that more?
Whoever runs it, whoever wins the nomination
and runs against Trump is to have to beat
Trump at his own game in the sense that just
going up there and doing wonky, deep political
discussions is just not going to defeat Trump.
I wish it were different, but I'm just sort
of recognizing the political reality that
we live in.
I hope whoever wins is ready for that.
Yeah.
Thanks.
All right.
I appreciate the phone call.
Thank you very much.
Yeah.
Great to hear
from you.